so hello everybody i am here with uh vin
armani also known as cyprian who
is a bitcoin developer quite known in
the bitcoin community he's also recently
been received into the orthodox church
and so there's quite a lot to talk about
with uh cyprian
he's been following my work for a while
we've been engaging on twitter we've
also you know we planned to talk a bit
earlier before and it just didn't work
out so this is actually a good time
since he has been received into the
church to figure out what is the
connection between
bitcoin and his journey into the church
and all the things that he's discovering
so i'm pretty excited about this
conversation today
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
so cyprian thank you for for joining me
today oh it's a pleasure and an honor
i've
as you said i've been following you for
for years now so
i've appreciated the work that you've
done and
and then when
you were started to become interested in
uh talking about bitcoin i was like okay
well if if this can happen it can happen
and i think that
now is definitely
we had spoken about it you know some
months ago but i i think now is
definitely the time to have this
conversation
and it's interesting because you know
you probably follow this that i'm i'm a
little suspicious about the coins of
bitcoin good just in terms of
what they are and what they're doing and
everything but it's funny there's a
personal connection now that's coming in
which is my son who's 16.
he said he said dad i really like to
start investing in in these cryptos and
i thought okay
you're 16 like he wanted to put almost
all the money he made like in his job
into this and so i said okay well let's
do it together so we put in we both put
in a certain amount um and uh and so
we're like we're trying to figure it out
together so it's like it's actually a
funny time because i'm doing this for
him but at the same time i guess i have
to figure it out you know i have to kind
of solve my problems with bitcoin um so
tell me a little bit how you got
involved into into bitcoin
i
was so i have a very
sort of
interesting history i've i've led a
pretty interesting life and
in 2012 i was in
las vegas i was in basically an all-cash
business and i had a lot of cash
and my background is as a software
developer so that's my professional
background since since my youth it's
kind of in the confluence of let's say
entertainment and media and art and
technology and so i've been
those are my two
sort of
life interests and so they've i found a
way to combine them throughout my career
and
i was looking at different options of
what can i do with this money like i
started out with money in my safe at
home and then i had to get a better safe
and then i spent all my days
after i would leave my home thinking
about
the money that was
in my home
and that wasn't very nice and so
las vegas is actually a great town for
cash as you could probably imagine i
imagine i've never been to las vegas but
i meant yes it's a great town for cash
and so you could do a lot of things in
cash much more than really i've been
able to do anywhere except for maybe
here in saipan and
you know i tried some things anonymous
private vaults and some other kind of
cool and fun things and then i recalled
that i had you know heard about this
thing bitcoin and i think maybe i had
seen some
either some article or some developer
friend reached out to me in in 2012 and
i
said ah let me check it out and found
somebody
that i could just do hand-to-hand
transactions with and did a few of those
in late 2012 the price was 15 per
bitcoin 2012 man yeah
so
so
i um
you know
spent a few thousand dollars doing that
and and ended up giving a lot away to
people and telling people and like oh
hey check this out it's cool the wallets
had just come out at that time the
first exchange mount gox was sort of
firing up
and then there were some other
interesting things
like this site that was on the dark web
called silk road
and i started to see oh these are this
is kind of interesting but i didn't
really think much of it and i was like
i don't know this doesn't really seem
like where i should be putting my money
now it doesn't seem like there's a lot
going on here
and but it's interesting
and
i sort of didn't pay attention to it and
fast forward to fall of 2013 so let's
say around thanksgiving time
and
here's this news like uh bitcoin to one
thousand dollars like it was the first
time that it had ever gone to a thousand
dollars so i was like a thousand dollars
and immediately i'm scrambling like
where oh this is where
i forgot
calling friends and everything like
remember those bitcoins i gave you in
all of this so
some was lost for sure but i recovered
enough let's just say i had a very
good
christmas
and uh it was very nice everybody was
very happy with the gifts they got and i
i pampered myself for my my good
investment and you know took some great
vacations and everything but i also said
this is insane
there's no because i was looking at it
and i said there's no reason there's no
fundamentals behind this to why
it would have gone to a thousand
and that's actually very important it's
actually very important and i think that
you know i i heard the previous
interview that you did and you began
saying you know that you had some
suspicions or you were a little bit
suspicious about bitcoin and i think
that's an appropriate feeling to have
so
i was also quite suspicious but
interested and then in 2014 i started
just developing on the side as doing
some hobby things some little projects
and whatnot
and
in 2016
i sort of dropped my previous life and
came out as like a libertarian like
which i couldn't do i was on a tv show
and so like
having a libertarian political event
publicly is not necessarily something
that you want to do while you're taking
a paycheck from a major network right to
be a star of a tv show so i was you know
i i kept quiet at that time and but then
i came out and started you know talking
and podcasting and whatnot and really
getting into the cryptocurrency side as
it was starting to make its next sort of
build up
and then started developing more and
from 2017 i founded a company called
cointext that's uh
we we just recently sold off assets to
that it's um
like an sms wallet basically so anybody
with the phone through sms could do this
and so i founded that company and and uh
was the lead developer of that and since
that time bitcoin has been my full time
it's been what i've focused on
exclusively uh with my professional
career and
i've really i've just really enjoyed
delving deep into it and since last year
i've been doing the school bitcoin
mystery school
which we can talk about how that came
about because it's directly tied into my
journey to orthodoxy
and
you know at this point we've got
hundreds of students who are in there it
takes place every month there's now a
continuing education course
and i wrote a book finish the book that
i had been writing called render unto
caesar that is
that is tying in these philosophical
elements of bitcoin
and i think that there's a really
important conversation to be had
um
the questions that i've heard you have
about bitcoin about trust about
authority about sovereignty about value
these are the questions no one is having
but it's when you
realize
how bitcoin addresses those things when
you realize what bitcoin has to say
about who we are as human beings and the
nature of reality
then um
then you really see the power of it and
then the idea that oh it could go from
fifteen to a thousand starts to not you
start to see what the fundamentals
really are so
so right now i mean my you know my time
is spent doing really more research and
development types of things and
educating my students and training up
new developers basically that's now
what's going on in the continuing
education of my school
so
it's it's full-time it's 100 full-time
bitcoin for me
all right so what i mean i guess that
begs the question so what is to you the
philosophical underpinning of or what is
the metaphysical or whatever
cosmological underpinning of bitcoin
what is it
in a nutshell
the project the bitcoin project
as described by its inventor satoshi
nakamoto is to be able to allow
any two parties to transact value to
transfer value with one another over a
communications channel which in this
case we're talking really about the
internet without the need for an
intermediary a trusted third party
really a financial institution
and
he in the introduction to the white
paper he says what is needed
is a
a payment a financial payment system
based on cryptographic proof instead of
trust
and it's an interesting idea
and when you delve into what is
cryptographic proof
really what i believe and and what it
has turned out and made sense to me that
he's saying is what is needed is a
system based on faith
instead of trust
and it's the
it's the difference between faith
and trust trust being that which we have
interpersonally between people which is
heavily based on reputation
and faith being that that sort of
foundational framework with which we we
predict what is going to happen in
reality so it's not that we like trust
that one plus one equals two
our relationship with one plus one
equaling two is faith
our it's not that we trust that the sun
is going to come up tomorrow of course
it might not
right there's always the chance that
something happens an asteroid hits the
sun blood who knows but
we trust that it's going to come up and
that or or our relationship with the sun
coming up tomorrow is not
trust in the same way that it's like hey
are you gonna pay me back that money
that i loaned you
right these are two
these are two different things
and so it's the system that we have now
is a trust-based system
it's a reputation-based system
it's the only way that we can move funds
from one person to another and exchange
values so as we move into this digital
realm
we have a system based on trust and i
think very soon
very very soon and canada may be one of
the places that it starts
people are going to start being cut off
from that system as they're being cut
off from other aspects of life
and that trust can be revoked
but you can't revoke the sun rising
tomorrow you can't revoke one plus one
equals two
and so
this is this is what satoshi is
delivering this is what bitcoin has the
capability of delivering okay and so
it's a very different
you know it's also like nails on a
chalkboard to me when people talk about
bitcoin is money and then go on to tell
you what all the things about money
bitcoin is definitely not money i've
been saying that for years now it's
something completely different
from money or at least
so i'll give you an example i'm sitting
here on my deck
i'll tell you how it how bitcoin is
money i'm sitting here on my deck
there's things that fly by
in the daytime i see birds i see their
silhouette but i also see butterflies
and at a certain distance they look
really similar
and then at night sometimes i'll see
bats
right but
it's it's like somebody somebody's
saying bitcoin has money is this is like
somebody saying oh see that butterfly
that's a bird
now let me tell you all about birds
and it's like well no maybe we need to
take a little closer look at this thing
and a little closer look at this other
one like yeah they make this flapping
motion and they move through the air
and maybe we could talk about flight and
aerodynamics and all of these things but
it
it is so different that we we need to
take a deeper look and we need to not be
categorizing it as something that has
come before because it really isn't
and so
i think that what i what i'm getting
from you is that
bitcoin because of the way it works
because it is somehow an impersonal
process it's a natural you could call it
like a natural process to be generous
like it's a natural process
uh and so something like its blessing
falls on whoever participates in the
process it's not and it actually doesn't
it doesn't have to do with human
intermediary authority
which is like you said what we're seeing
right now is especially with with this
with the pandemic and the way it's
playing out is that we're seeing methods
and ways in which people can be excluded
from systems uh radically and kind of in
a surprising way uh people even you can
see we've been seeing people get their
bank accounts removed and paypal
accounts dropped and all this kind of
happens
um
so i guess i i understand that but i
also wonder because bitcoin is dependent
on systems that are related to these
systems of power including the internet
no connectivity uh and also traceability
there's a certain amount of traceability
just by the fact that you even though
people will say that it's anonymous and
that the the the coin is not lit
related to you
the trace right of you
whatever wherever you are right doing
these transactions is something which
can be can be traced and then will is
ultimately linked to these systems of
power
so i mean that's my impression unless
there's maybe there's ways around it for
people that are
super tech savvy and are the dark web
and all this stuff but it seems like
it's at least like
for most most people they'll have to
also have to use all these
intermediary uh
intermediary organizations like
exchanges and wallets and all of this
stuff uh you know and then to get the
money you get it
if you need to use this money you have
to have some form of bank account like
there's the system
the way that you're talking about it i
kind of get it but it seems like it's
far
it's still far from
doing exactly what you're saying
or am i wrong
well
interestingly you are
you are right
for one story of bitcoin so bitcoin
actually has two
parallel narratives that are happening
and it's it actually comes from the very
start and the way that satoshi put it
into place so there's bitcoin the
concept
the concept of bitcoin and with this
concept of bitcoin that
it really actually isn't
dependent on the internet per se any way
that any digital means of attaching to
machines you would be able to do it
um
the cryptography and all of that the
consensus rules all of these you can
make your own networks and this is kind
of the idea of the concept so this is
what i'm primarily focused on and this
is where the let's say
this is the lifeboat
the lifeboat is in the concept but you
are absolutely right in terms of this
other thing and how bitcoin has
manifested itself
and the reason it's manifested itself is
because satoshi added in as
as these things always are like
the traditional mythological structure
in order for him to build this thing he
had to add in this
seed of corruption if you will
and the seed of corruption was basically
as he was building this he built the
system and he's like okay the system
works great but why would anybody when
this thing has no price it's not worth
anything why would anybody
utilize their computer to keep this
running which was something he needed a
critical mass of people to do
why would anybody do this
and so if people go to the white paper
there is a small little section that's
called the incentive section it's only
nine sentences
and basically what he came up with was
this idea and he said okay here's what
i'll do i will incentivize people to
keep their computers up and running
because if they'll keep them up and
running and running the software every
10 minutes
somebody based upon their percentage of
computer power that they're giving to
the network is going to get some of
these coins
and i will also make the amount that is
going to be given total
on this particular network this
particular game because each bitcoin
network is really a game that's taking
place so the reason why would someone
play this game because a chance to win
some money
and so
in the beginning
it wasn't worth anything and everybody
that was doing this
yeah there was some idea that they would
get some money but it wasn't why they
were doing it they were interested in
what could this bring to society
or what could this do in the future they
tech heads early adopters whatever
as it started to get a price and the
main reason that it got a price was as i
said these these dark web markets so as
it started to get a price one cent and
then one dollar and all of this you
started to get this inkling of people
wanting to
just
run their computers to generate the
coins to them before everybody who had a
wallet everybody who was on the network
was also a minor there were very few
people on yeah right so everybody was a
miner if you were on the network you
were a miner
then you started to get into this
situation where of course people were
like well i can trade it there's a place
to trade it people will buy it so let me
just run machines and then we start to
get into this mining industry and what
inevitably happened
is that
some people had coins
they want those they want that value to
go up
and there's a certain segment it's the
largest segment of people involved in
bitcoin it's almost everyone who's a
bitcoin thought leader
they are dedicated and they even say
they call it ngu technology they are
dedicated to the number go up
uh mythos and ideology they are
dedicated to the price go up
idea and the only way to get the price
to go up is you've got to get more
people
to play the game
basically to buy in like you and your
son are doing more people to want
bitcoin basically yes and the way that
you do that the way that they do it
is it's basically the final corruption
of satoshi of what satoshi because what
was he playing with it's a bit cynical
he's playing with greed
right he was leveraging greed yeah now
if he doesn't do that
because he didn't have to
he could have just said either one it's
not it's unlimited supply
or two he could have said well i'll just
dump them all onto the network to start
and then i'll just give them to my
friends
the network would have worked exactly
the same
what makes bitcoin bitcoin would have
been exactly the same but he added in
this incentive to start out to get
people to bootstrap it to get people to
use it
and so now what we have is we have that
incentive run amok
and so when people see bitcoin
so you look at bitcoin and you say
well there's all these intermediaries
what are you talking about it's a it's
something to eliminate intermediaries
yeah all of the intermediaries are based
around the price going up
all of this is around the price going up
and if bitcoin is going to be killed
and the btc network is going to be
killed in this process so people who are
buying into the btc network the price
may go up but no one will be using the
network because they buy it on coinbase
they buy it on paypal they buy it from
some exchange they leave it on the
exchange they put put their us dollars
or canadian dollars up
and then they don't move it on the
network and as the price goes up they
sell it and they take us and canadian
dollars back
this is not bitcoin
because bitcoin's whole purpose is to
remove the banks
to remove the financial institutions and
everybody that uses a financial
institution to enter into the game
is not doing bitcoin they're doing the
this other story this number go up thing
right which is a part of bitcoin
right but it's like a
again it's the seed of corruption that's
always planted at the beginning right
this is the typical mythological pattern
and so
i kind of i mean i kind of get it but
for example like so the idea would be
that satoshi put in
limited amount
in order to create rarity and that
rarity would then create desire
and that desire then would would
incentivize people to
mine the coin let's say
it's the appearance the appearance of
rarity and the appearance of scarcity
right so these same individuals will say
oh it's the first digitally scarce asset
which is just
absurd
it's an absurd statement to make
because
the digits in digital are ones and zeros
the number one and the number zero
cannot be scarce
and also the idea that anything digital
would be scarce
i mean this video could be viewed how
many times on how many machines by how
many people because it's digital the
whole idea of the digital revolution is
that it's nothing is scares right right
so to say this is the first digitally
scarce asset you're that's a game that's
being played on you
that's that's someone who is playing the
game of oh as we say buy my bags
right so
he gave but he gave the appearance if
people read the incentive section it's
very clear it's very cynical actually
like he's he gives he says i'm going to
give this appearance because
i need to do something to get people
and you know what if it's good enough
that they're like ah it's kind of like
okay it kind of feels like scarcity
maybe it will be value valuable someday
he's putting the the pieces the pattern
of what makes something valuable
so that people will play the game but it
still is just a game
so but i i think i don't totally follow
you are you saying that bitcoin is not
scarce like there is absolutely not
there's no limit of bitcoin no no and i
can and i can prove that to you so
so bitcoin btc
has been forked many times now so
what happens when there's a fork is the
some set of nodes decide that they're
not going to accept the same
transaction rules so the same rules of
the game
and they continue
on with a new
ledger new history basically it's a
schism
okay so like it's like 10 54. so bitcoin
has had a 1054 and it split into bitcoin
and bitcoin cash now similar with the
church split
they share the same saints before right
they have all the same history before
but now what you have is you have two
sets of saints that come off of here two
sets of traditions two sets of histories
that come off
and you can split that five ways from
sunday
and every time you split it
you get a new 21 million coins so that
first that first split created 42
million
and then
two years later or one year later
uh one of the splits bch split into two
again bsv and bch and then just last
year bch split again
into
uh bitcoin abc which is now called ecash
and uh bch on this side so even just
between those
on which by the way satoshi nakamoto
could come back and spend his coins
because he he's a he's the first saint
right right so the the
the coins that he mined he can spend
them on every single one of those chains
so you already don't have 21 million
coins
you already don't
every time there's a split satoshi's
coins double
the number of coins double so
anybody can split his coins double two
yeah everybody everybody who was holding
coins at the time of the split
they double they double so it's not so
there is a sense there's a sense in
which the scarcity is
somewhat preserved because whoever
already has coins
has the same ratio compared to the all
the coins that are possible let's say
sure but sure but there is no
limit to how many times
it can be it can be split so there are
split up i mean those are just a few
that i'm mentioning there's bitcoin gold
there's bitcoin private there's bitcoin
candy all of these are traded on
exchanges now they don't trade for very
much yeah
right but
the idea here is about scarcity and so
this is just provably that well it's not
scarce because i can i can if i've got
somebody who's willing to bind it i can
fork a coin tomorrow it's very easy i
just pull the code down change one
consensus rule let it run on on
mining rigs and boom we're done
so there's no there's no
barrier to entry for someone to
inflate the currency now they can't
inflate it necessarily in the exact same
game
but that almost
that almost doesn't matter because what
we see is that to compare it to
something like gold
where
that's this is the face versus trust
thing right like when we talk about gold
being scarce it's like well
yeah the number of
atoms within the earth like the earth
sphere is there's a finite number
but in this case there truly is no
finite number
so it's it's quite different and it's
but but you can make people perceive it
and that's the important part it's the
perception and that's what's giving it
that's what's giving it the value in the
market there's no doubt that it has it
all right
so what role do you see it playing then
like let's say in the world because
if it if it if it can be split in
indefinitely and you know
um it's not based on on uh trust of the
people let's say that that are
instigating these how do you see it
working and what do you see its purpose
the purpose is well we're about to see
the purpose
so the purpose of of
bitcoin is to be the parallel economy to
be the lifeboat
to
give the capability for the
i mean just to be quite frank to to give
those individuals who do not want to
take the mark
you know
to give them the opportunity to actually
have a society and a financial system
because this is this is what is coming
and this is the um
this is sort of the the the end the end
piece but
yes bitcoin outside of number go up
bitcoin is not very valuable while
everybody still has access to the
financial networks
so if everybody still has access to the
financial networks there's not a lot of
utility in bitcoin besides the gambling
and the number going up
so so you're saying that if once once
people start get really cut off from the
financial system then then all of a
sudden the reason for bitcoin and the
value bitcoin is going to become it's
going to be apparent and it's going to
be
come more useful let's say for people
yes but it won't but the price of
bitcoin in that case is going to not
matter as much because
it's really the concept it's the idea
that you can pop up a bitcoin network
whenever and wherever you want to using
this so it's not that we're going to see
one network it's that we might see you
know for every one of these communities
that's around we might see an individual
network within that community and so
it's actually the knowledge of
how do you constitute a bitcoin network
what it what are the
principles being used the cryptographic
principles the proof of work
this is the important part
because if you have that and and some
ability to to manifest that in code
then you can pop these things up so
so yes it's
in some ways i'm very glad that the
number go up is happening because were
the number go up not and i'm not poo
pooing it for that reason like
thank god it's there because
if it wasn't there
this idea may never ha have even reached
the minds it would have just like died
on the vine and it would have been some
apocryphal thing
and nobody would have even seen the
white paper in the code right but
because that was there because people
are actually
looking at it there will be the
capability when this happens in the i
think not too far future
for certain individuals to be able to
reconstitute themselves and to have
an ability to not have to do the things
that are going to be necessary to remain
within the
within the system right
um and so
then how do you i mean how do you solve
the
how do you solve the i guess would you
would have like closed networks like you
would you could bait you would basically
set up closed networks that wouldn't be
connected to the big ones like connected
to the big ones that have
uh authority um and then run run it on
that is i guess that's the only final
solution to this
yeah and that's where
the real
it's not and i won't call it even
innovation but the real revelation of
bitcoin comes in and the real revelation
of bitcoin is called proof of work
and it's a unique
it's the first time that humans have
ever had
this capability and basically what it
it's it's an
it's an epistemological tool it's not a
technological tool because what it
allows is it allows two people or more
an unlimited number of people
who have no interaction with each other
or who might even have
an adversarial relationship one another
with one another to come to consensus on
events having happened in the real world
and that that event being that some
amount of measurable work was done some
amount of measurable labor took place
somewhere
by someone
and this is this is the this is the
mining
this is yes so
mining
so we call it mining and the the term
mining actually comes from that little
incentive section
and it's the
again it's the poison pill if you will
because satoshi has a sort of
a side remark or maybe perhaps to wet
people's whistle a bit and to to
to get at the greed he says you know
this system the way that i've put it
together this pattern of the limited
supply and it being sort of trickled out
and emitted out he said it's like gold
miners mining gold that it gets more
expensive the more you pull out of the
ground
so he said i've put this in here he put
it there yeah and it was it was debate
right so the even the idea of mining
is
it sort of obfuscates
proof of work was before mining
proof of work had been around for for
at that point uh
over a decade
so proof of proof of work was being used
and really what it is is it is it is a
way of leveraging the laws of nature
so
mathematical laws
that again we have faith in and in my
school bitcoin mystery school the first
day of our sort of novice initiation
class the students actually do this
proof of work by hand
and it's by it's doing and watching it
that they actually develop the faith as
well because you see that oh yeah i can
predict the future and we can make this
more or less difficult and we can tell
mathematically how long it's going to
take somebody to complete this task so i
can give you a task jonathan and know
that on average it's going to take you
two minutes to do it or i could give you
a new task and know on average it's
going to take you five minutes to do it
or 10 minutes so i can actually charge
you
right i can charge you in your time
charge you in your work and anyone in
the world
seeing that what you build from out of
this work which is basically a number
that you generate can verify and
validate whether they knew us whether
they saw what was going on they can just
look at the information and say if
they're in a bunker they could look at
it and say oh yeah this guy did 10
minutes worth of work okay so that is so
i guess
what i'm starting to understand is that
is where the value
yes comes from the value comes from
provable
time
energy that is spent so these numbers
don't come out of a out of a box you
have to spend so much energy and time in
order to generate uh
a coin and therefore that is the value
it's like a sweat equity type value
where you know that somebody okay that's
that's useful for me to think about it
that way
all of a sudden it's not it's not so
much just a magical thing like a
completely random random process yeah
and it's important for everybody to
think about it that way and it's why
it's so frustrating to me when i see
people who are bitcoin thought leaders
who spend zero time on explaining proof
of work they say oh it's a proof-of-work
thing
and then they just go right past it but
proof of work is everything in bitcoin
all of the other stuff had been done
the there's also public key cryptography
which is doing something similar and
that it's utilizing
the
laws of nature
it's utilizing
things that we can have faith will be
the same and are verifiable by everyone
because it's utilizing math
and and basically in that way it's
proving not ownership
but actually it's it's very interesting
it's proving that you know a number that
is fundamentally unguessable
so it's not ownership it's actually
knowledge
and this is why i tell people that this
is not a technology this is an
epistemology
because really what it's about is it's
about knowledge and the verification
that someone knows something without
knowing you without seeing you you can
present me some set of data and i can
say oh this guy knows a specific number
and that's that this is your private key
this is how you're able to spend your
bitcoins and that by the same token you
can present me some other data and i can
say oh
this guy has done x amount of work
so x number of what's called hashes so
what's interesting is that right now
it's actually this proof of work which
is being attacked that is the media the
the let's say the official channels are
are attacking proof of work as the
reason why bitcoin is bad why it's a
problem because it's environmentally
unsound it's using up all our resources
et cetera et cetera so how how do you
see that strange situation
oh it's not strange so when satoshi
released the
the first
version of the software he released it
onto a mailing list a cryptography
mailing list called the mets down
cryptography mailing list
now this was a mailing list with
basically professional cryptographers
mathematicians uh an industry list
and
there were criticisms there was only one
cryptographer one old school
cryptographer called hal finney who was
a big supporter on the list now i've
written a lot and i believe how finney
actually was satoshi nakamoto and that
he had
basically given himself a double
identity so that he could support
himself there's also some other um
things that hal had been through the
cryptography that's involved
years before that
was considered a munition by the
government and there's a
one of the first programs called pretty
good privacy that was developed by a
gentleman named phil zimmerman he was
actually uh
investigated
for an arms control violation by the
department of state he was potentially
going to be held up as the same that you
would for like selling a nuclear weapon
uh that's yes that's right i don't
understand why would that why would that
why would that be the case
this is uh
yeah good good so
cryptography the history of cryptography
this type of cryptography mathematical
cryptography
dates back to world war ii
and this is what was going on with at
bletchley park with the enigma machine
and uh you know cracking the german the
german codes uh that was where the first
computer was actually made the first
digital computer colossus the the reason
for the existence of the computers that
we have
was this was cryptography was codes
and
these were considered to be
basically state secrets they were
completely in control uh in under the
control of the nsa i'll read you i found
an interesting quote lately that i said
i'm going to i'm going to read this to
uh
so
in um in 1976
when this
when this technology was basically
dropped by there's there's six guys that
are involved um
one one of them
is a guy by the name of whitfield diffy
and his quote he said um
after they released their paper he said
the national security agency's crypto
monopoly was effectively terminated and
this is what he says he said every
company every citizen now had routine
access to the sorts of cryptographic
technology that not many years ago
ranked alongside the atomic bomb as a
source of power that's how valuable the
cryptography that's used in bitcoin was
viewed
let's say from world war ii
through
the the 70s and 80s that what's being
used is munitions grade cryptography if
you send a message using this no
government can decrypt it so these were
states were holding these things as
secrets so the idea to think that it's
like these are this is a weapon
of incredible power
incredible power and people don't know
that that's the case
right so this is one of the things this
is why i do my school the second day we
spend it all on cryptography and t and
showing people that like yeah right in
your bitcoin wallet is the capability
for you to do
this type of cryptography and send these
types of messages most people have no
idea right this is not part of the
number go up narrative
right so
the for when going back to to satoshi
releasing this when he released it
the president or one of the founders of
the electronic frontier foundation as a
matter of fact happened to be on that
list and his criticism at that time this
is 2009
this is a day after it's released no one
is even mining it it's running on like
three people's laptops he's saying i i
just wish that we we don't have more
computers running this
you know uh
spewing carbon into the atmosphere
so
okay that's hilarious
yes and this is and this is 100 percent
true the ma the emails are there you can
go and look so this is a purely
ideological
attack
against something that is a threat to
something else and that's what people
should understand
bitcoin does not use very much
electricity whatsoever
and uh especially if you've got one of
these
secondary networks
you know there's bitcoin like
btc that's using i don't know 90 of the
electricity and the reason it's using
that much electricity is because the
price is so high
because as we're talking about like
the value
is correlated
to how much work is being done
so if it costs me
ten thousand dollars to generate one
bitcoin i obviously can't sell that
bitcoin for less than ten thousand
dollars
right and if bitcoin is going for 50 000
i've got to do 50 000 worth of work well
that 50 000 translates to more
electricity right so but the price is
apropos of nothing jonathan that's the
point
it's the price is only related to how
many people are coming on to
in into the
into the number go up cult
but there is a way in which
that proof of work is is going to
stabilize the price like it's going to
it is going to limit it going back to 15
let's say because if that happens then
the whole system stops everybody stops
mining if it goes down to a certain
level it just stops
no you don't think so no no people
people would keep mining they would just
it would use a lot less electricity
the issue the issue and the number go up
cult will will you know present this and
to a certain degree it's correct
the issue
is that the way to disrupt the network
is to acquire 51
of
the total amount of work that's being
done at any given time right
so this is a 51
if you do that you can control the
consensus
this is built in this is the threat
and so the more it's worth the more
it's work is being done to like to
outperform the others
yes and the number go up cult calls this
security
they say the the higher the price the
more secure the network is
this is not really true
uh because there's only a limited number
of things that you can do with that 51
percent
and
you can always cut that if if you are
you know if you have a community that's
relatively small and some attacker comes
on it's relatively easy to switch out
the software and to cut them out of the
loop and this has actually been done in
bitcoin forks in what are what have been
called hash wars so this is like not
theoretical what i'm saying this is
actually been done on multi-billion
dollar networks where you you have a few
miners who have a lot of the hash power
and they've sent secret versions of
software to one another
to cut out an attacker who's been there
so there's a lot of ways to mitigate it
um
there are there are bitcoin coins that
have traded for fifty dollars
like i say there was a time when bitcoin
was trading for fifteen dollars and it
was just as safe and secure then
as it is now
in terms of the actual attacks or
anything that happened to it so it's
it's really
you know if there's one network yes it's
a problem
if it's just btc
but if if i'm like i don't need that
network i've got my community that i'm
trading with we'll just fire up our own
and we'll just make it so that only we
can utilize the network
no problem
so so this is why i say there's two
stories
and one story takes you down one
particular path
and the other story takes you down a
completely different path where you
realize it's a tool
that anybody can use that's open
permissionless and anyone can fire up a
network
so
one of the i guess one of the
the suspicions or one of the things that
is strange about bitcoin is the fact
that it was
created by an anonymous person and so
this of course
opens up the thought that there's
something else going on that there that
it's actually being released by uh
some kind of state actor or something
more nefarious um
what do you think is the reason why it's
it's been released by an anonymous
person like why do you think this was
was it that maybe the danger this
cryptographic danger of being suspect by
a government or something like that
yeah well like i say i believe that it
was this gentleman hal finney so he was
the first person to support bitcoin on
this mailing list he was the first
person besides satoshi nakamoto to mine
he was the first person to receive a
bitcoin transaction he received the
first bitcoin transaction he was also
the first person to ever tweet the word
bitcoin so his his twitter handle is
still there at hal finn and you could go
down to january
uh january 9 2009 and there's a tweet
that says run in bitcoin and it's
interesting because it's kind of a
pilgrimage site
for bitcoiners you know you'll see
throughout the years people have gone
and they leave little it's like going to
a tomb because he he he died of als
actually okay so he became paralyzed he
died in 2014 uh and his disappearance
and becoming paralyzed coincided with
satoshi's disappearance but hal finney
was the second developer also on this
pgp
project so he actually witnessed his
friend phil zimmerman he was actually
working for pgp until he died um he
witnessed his friend phil zimmerman be
investigated and almost be and go
through the whole thing am i it's a
crazy story mit ended up sort of
stepping in and printing the code in a
book and they said it's freedom of the
freedom of the press and all it was it's
really cool and it started the whole
free software open source movement
hal finney was involved
so having gone through that
it would have made a lot of sense for
him knowing that there was a possibility
that this would happen
to create an anonymous identity
and to put it out
the good thing about bitcoin is that the
the concepts that bitcoin uses are
they're all they all precede bitcoin
so these are all concepts that had been
tested for
decades and the the cryptography
the the hashing all of that is you use
it every day so we actually couldn't do
commerce on the internet without it when
you see that little lock up on on your
uh browser bar when you go to an
ecommerce site and you see that lock
click on that go into the certificate
right you'll see
words like sha-256 that's the hashing
algorithm that's used in bitcoin you'll
see uh rsa that's the public key
cryptography system so these are all
used um so
and the code is open source
so it's been gone over with the
fine-tooth comb since that time there's
nothing hidden this is known technology
it works it can be reconstituted from
scratch
so
you know yeah i think i think the state
actor thing is mostly not the not
bitcoin itself but rather create
how can i say this to create a threat
which is strong enough so that it will
justify the government
creating its own digital currency which
will have many strings attached it seems
like this is happening now i saw an
article recently about
creating programmable digital currency
in england for example where
where uh
in the code of the currency you can
decide what it can be
spent on you could decide that the money
will
lose its value after a certain time they
can only be used by certain people like
this is something which is live
happening right now in terms of and it
seems to be
in some way a reaction
to
the crypto world saying okay well we
need to now create our government you
know because this is all dangerous this
is this is dark web this is all this
illegal stuff we need to create our own
digital currency to compete with that uh
and people will just accept it because
the rest is dangerous like the other
stuff is dangerous yeah well let's go
down that rabbit hole for a minute
because it's actually
it's actually much crazier and i think
your audience will appreciate this and i
urge them to go down this rabbit hole
themselves
um so what you're talking about is a
central bank digital currency that's
also called the cbdc
and
there is a cbdc
that was created by the federal reserve
that is ready to be released
the
federal reserve had actually announced
that they were going to release a what
they called a discussion paper it's
basically a white paper they said that
was going to happen in july it hasn't
there's some legislation that's in this
latest bill in congress that is probably
what they were waiting for
but what's interesting about this is it
was created this central bank digital
currency was created by
uh the boston fed and the mit
um media labs digital currency
initiative
now what's interesting about this
digital currency so people can go look
it up this is not secret you go look up
the digital currency initiative at mit
that's who created it you can go and
look up federal reserve and and that
google it the cbdc this is this is known
um what's interesting about this digital
currency initiative is in 2016
mit media lab reached out and hired
the three basically top btc
bitcoin developers the guys who held the
keys what we call commit access the keys
to the code the people who were deciding
what goes into the code and what doesn't
go into the code so this is gavin
andreessen who basically had the keys
handed to him by satoshi nakamoto he was
like let's say the heir of satoshi
nakamoto now disgraced within the
bitcoin community corey fields and
vladimir vanderland vladimir vanderlian
is com is particularly important because
he's considered fundamentally the lead
developer he's the guy with the most
he's the bishop
right with the most power
to be able to determine what goes into
the code or not
so they hired them in 2016 because there
was no these guys were working in an
open source world and they had no income
so they had no direct bitcoin income
and so along comes mit and says ah come
and work
on this research project just you can
just do bitcoin research and all of that
now if people go back what's great is to
go back on the way back machine
and go and look at the digital currency
initiative site in 2016
and you scroll down and you see that
indeed from the very start
they were working on
federal reserve uh central bank digital
currencies from the very start
when
like two months before
it wasn't that the federal reserve was
going to announce that yes this had been
created for them by mit uh vladimir
vanderland who was the last one left
basically
quit at the digital media lab uh quit
quit at the uh digital currency
initiative and went si he and went
basically silent he's basically as much
silent really so what we come down to is
the lead developers
of bitcoin of btc of bitcoin core the
main software are the ones who built
the exact currency that you're talking
about
for the federal reserve
they're the ones who built it because
again
money
at the end of the day
it was about well i gotta feed my kids
like how long is that you know this is
we're seeing that this is the narrative
right the i gotta feed my kids narrative
is leading to everything now one
additional tidbit that's very
interesting
the head of mit uh media lab is
gentleman by the name of joy ito
right around the time that the epstein
scandal broke he was forced to quit he
was forced to quit why was he forced to
quit because it was found out that
around the exact same time that they
started the digital currency initiative
jeffrey epstein was donating a ton of
money
and there's emails some of it even in
the name of another individual that
we've seen quite a bit who used to run
a tech giant
uh and is now sort of uh retired from
out of that in his name an email saying
this is coming from that gentleman but
please mark it down as coming from
epstein
okay now i'm not saying what that was
going to fund but when you understand
that the federal reserve was secretly
funding
their
uh centralized version of bitcoin using
the uh
using the exact characters who were at
the same time working on bitcoin core
people can go people can go down that
rabbit hole themselves but it's just
like all of this is real right so joy
ito he was disgraced he had to resign it
was a big you could go look at new york
times all of that because epstein was
giving money under the table to them and
he was hiding it yeah
so it's coming no so jonathan
again like
that's coming
that's here it was built by the same
people that built bitcoin
and it's not that it's a reaction to big
it's it's not that it's a reaction to
bitcoin because bitcoin's bad
it's that it's a reaction to bitcoin
because bitcoin is powerful
so they were like no we need to have our
own bitcoin but no proof of work none of
this stuff we control yeah
we control it centralized but all the
rest the cryptography and everything
because bitcoin works
so it'll continue to be a kind of uh
fiat currency but but it will be digital
and it will be traceable and it will
have all the let's say the cryptog
cryptographic power of uh
yep
and programmable as well which means you
can get money in your account and then
if you write the wrong thing on twitter
the numbers can vanish
yes
yeah or or just be locked yeah and and
it yeah it doesn't matter if it vanishes
because they can also create as many as
they want right because the proof of
work is what's controlling the emission
schedule
but when they want to print new money
no problem yeah they just pre they just
press a button still don't believe me
they're not going to give themselves a
21 billion limit okay like that's not
what's gonna happen with the central
bank
but it's mostly the idea of being able
to to lock people out of the economy in
this days that we haven't seen yet
this is i mean that is
the key it's and it's not just lock
people out i think actually one of the
most
nefarious and frightening
scenarios is uh expirable
money yep that's right so they send you
the funds and they're like if you don't
spend this in 30 days it's
gone you know
money self-destruct a soft communism
you know you get your allowance and you
also can only spend it on certain things
and then it then it then it disappears
yeah
so this is this is here yeah it's ready
to be it's ready to be released uh i
can't imagine that it's not going to be
tied to all of these other things yeah
and
that same um digital currency initiative
built for japan
for
china
for
there there were a few there's like
seven or eight countries that they built
for for uk
um so
it's all coming from the same place
it's all coming from the same place and
it's all based around the fundamentals
of bitcoin
all right so i guess like now that we're
at the end of this very dark scenario i
i do want to hear about i do want to
hear about in and of course i'll laugh
when i say that i do want to hear about
how this how this whole process kind of
led you to orthodoxy because it to me it
seems like a strange just a yeah a
strange thing how how these things can
be related
it is it is very strange actually so
you know as i said i've been working in
this space
for
uh since since 2017 full blast and i've
gotten a chance to work uh you know with
some of the biggest companies
on really great projects but i've also
been lucky that i've been able to work
with individuals who i was ideologically
aligned with so
it hasn't been these sorts of exchanges
and the coin bases and whatnot it's been
uh you know
companies like bitcoin.com and others
who are more focused around this vision
of sovereignty of financial sovereignty
and people having that and bitcoin being
able to deliver it
and
uh
when the
all of this goofiness started in 2020 i
was living with my family in southern
california and i knew
uh this is not the place to be so i saw
in march when the things started
happening i was like i know this pattern
like i know exactly where this is going
and we had been planning to
to move to saipan
but
it got it got very much moved up and we
we found ourselves here april 5th okay
so this is recent i thought you had been
in saipan for a while no no we came here
because of that so we we came here
fundamentally as refugees
and i i've had a strong spiritual
spiritual bent and i've been involved in
a lot of different
very powerful things so i had a very
long relationship that many people know
many years with ayahuasca
and plant medicine and those types of
things so i had a
you know i had a i've always had a
strong understanding of the mystical
like the realness of the mystical in
other words like no question that like
there are spirits there is a spirit
world like they interact with us you can
speak to them and i think people have
had the experiences that i've had you
walk away like oh it's real
right like real shamanist
shamanism type experiences
but in about in 2019
2018 i uh
i started delving into back into
christianity and it was through uh i had
seen a christopher hitchens speech
around the time that he was
uh you know dying of cancer
and where he said that he was reading
dharma mccullough's book christianity a
history of christianity the first three
thousand years i still know this is very
interesting that this avowed atheist
would be like crowing about how
excellent this book was
and so
i got it on audiobook and it was sort of
over the course of the year when i would
do yard work on sundays it was like okay
let me just dig into this right hadn't
been to church since i was a kid
you know had been exploring all of these
other things and it
it really i was really struck getting
back into the ancient church about how
little i didn't know what in terms of
that history
and
then started into a a practice of prayer
of course i don't know what i'm doing
and fasting
and i started to get some and i was
working on bitcoin and some very
difficult problems at the time and
through the fasting
and through this what i what i now
understand was was
developing a system of prayer through
that
i actually started getting solving all
of these problems like i would be in the
middle of a fast and i was getting and i
was like okay this is so kind of very
mercenary you know what i mean where i
was like okay i'm getting so much
insights from the past yeah yes exactly
and so
when i
when i came to saipan i said well
i'm going to actually take up
and and where i had gotten the fasting
stuff was it was mainly a lot of
pentecostal that i was consuming
pentecostal stuff and and i was like oh
this is very interesting and it was
resonating with me like i said oh
there's a spirit thing and so when we
got here
we ended up we had this beautiful house
right on the beach that was that we
lucked into and i just started morning
and evening
a practice of prayer
and
and
i don't know i don't know how it was
that that i started doing the jesus
prayer
right so i don't know how i ran across
it maybe it was from a pentecostal thing
but i said i'm gonna do this and i'm
just gonna this is where i'm gonna go
and i'm gonna start with this and it was
actually in
it was coming back off the beach
that i
had this
flash
that said
you're going to do this school it's
going to be called bitcoin mystery
school you're going to teach these
things you've been working on these
things you're going to teach these
things and i was like nobody wants to
what this doesn't even make any sense
but i said okay i'm going to follow it
right because i just i was writing my
book i was getting a lot of insights
from my book from this practice of
prayer
and
i just announced hey i'm going to do
this thing put a thing up and
somebody who i had spoken to in the past
reached out to me and said
uh
cool guy and he said hey uh there's some
guys in my parish uh i'm orthodox i knew
he was orthodox like there's these guys
in my parish
uh
we would like to all do this like as a
group we've been talking about like
things that may be needed in the future
we think bitcoin's important we'd like
to do this as a group
i said oh awesome you guys can be like
my guinea pigs i'll do a private course
you guys will be the very first course
and it was in that course
that one of the
participants in the course was the
priest of the parish okay and uh it was
in it was
so it was in that time
and sort of some i don't know there was
something going on with those guys it
was really awesome and um
him in particular i was like
he's a really unique guy and i was like
and i said i i wonder if he's got any
youtube videos or anything like that and
i just started that night in between the
first and second i just started watching
all these videos of him there weren't
that many but things that he had done
and it just really spoke to me and and
sort of at the end of the class i said
hey uh father
you know i don't know if you're open to
this but could we talk about
maybe you helping me with my prayer
like i would like to be more effective
with my prayer
and
and so it was over the course of several
months of him and i just having a
a what's become a very deep relationship
that um
obviously my prayer got much better and
he uh you know sent me the orthodox
prayer book and started talking about if
you want to do this little did i know
that i was becoming a catechumen and uh
you know then then
things just things got really really
potent and powerful and
honestly to a point that was beyond
like i was going really far in terms of
my prayer i had like i say i had
previous this previous
shamanistic experience so i was like oh
i'm gonna try to approach it like that
and things just got actually really
serious to a point where i was like oh
this is too much
like this is
i can't do this and so it was funny like
the next time i said i need to talk with
you the next time we had a conversation
and like what i was wanting to say to
him was i need to be at the church
like because i would like to continue
this practice but i can't do this
outside of a framework of the church i
realize that now right like i'm going to
hurt myself
mentally even physically right so i was
like
and it was and it was through that that
he said okay then let's uh let's
formally start your catechism
and so we did that and then um
just through i mean it was very
providential the way everything fell
into place that he and a reader from his
parish
you know we arranged brought them out
here to saipan
they uh
you know yeah we set up a little chapel
it was beautiful they did the first
orthodox services that had ever been
done here baptized me in the ocean
actually happened to be crazily enough
i'm married to a russian orthodox woman
and my kids are baptized yes and my
and my children are baptized russian
orthodox this is for how long have you
been married i've i have uh six years i
have a five-year-old yeah i have a
five-year-old and i have a uh she's
almost three three-year-old two and a
half year old
that those were the only times i had
ever been in a orthodox church where the
baptism isn't my children that's right
but it's so interesting like she never
pushed it on me yeah right um
but it's so obviously it really fell
into place and then so they came came
here did my baptism sanctified our
marriage in the church which is
beautiful so we got to have a church
wedding here
and um
and yeah since since that time
it's been
it's it's actually crazy things have
happened to happen you know after they
left a few weeks later
randomly we're out on the beach fourth
of july is fourth of july as a matter of
fact we're out on the beach
i take my daughter into the water i turn
around sitting in the seat where i had
been sitting is a priest
orthodox priest in saipan
exactly and i'm like what and all of our
all like all of our we were out there
celebrating so all of our friends were
there and their mouths are like wide
open
he's in a full black cossack
big silver pectoral cross my wife is
crying
and it's like
he's a mission
priest he's got a a parish in
taiwan he answers he's like got this i
forget what it i forget what it's called
it's kind of it's like the equivalent of
like an embassy sort of thing that the
russian church does so he answers
directly to the patriarch
and so
he said you know what no russian priests
have been here for 200 years we have the
records but i just decided that i was
going to come here and guam and you
people are the first people that i've
ran into and you didn't know you were
orthodox
that's hilarious my wife saw him walking
yeah with his cossack and everything
wait she calls him in russian yeah
and he's like comes over and sits down
and then i walk up and i'm like what
else this is this is incredible and so
so then we got we had more you know more
services here and actually some of the
the people who are here kind of there's
a little crypto community two of the
brothers
after experiencing that decided that
they were going to become
catechumens as well so it was like it
was pretty great they were
because it's been it's been incredible
the things that have happened here and
so
so i'm
you know part of the
part of what was happening with with
bitcoin was that the patterns and the
reflection that i was that i was seeing
and a lot of this is in is in the book
that i wrote render into caesar was that
it really is a reflection of the trinity
the things that are happening in bitcoin
so the way that bitcoin lays itself out
the the pattern that's there is it's
like it's a very much an echo
of the way that the trinity is is laid
out in the tradition and so
these were the types of things that were
happening and so for me
um
you know i tell people like it's because
bitcoin brought me to orthodoxy
and so it's just the series of events
that happened
i mean
because it makes no sense
right like the way that this whole thing
happened it makes no sense
the way that it's laid itself out makes
zero sense but but yet here i am yeah
here you are that's for sure so can you
explain i like can you give us a hint of
why bitcoin what it has how it manifests
the trinity because maybe it's too
complicated but i i when you said that i
was like okay i
i would like to know that sure sure sure
so
so bitcoin is
so bitcoin is basically the interaction
as is as are so many things of
some set of
foundational and fundamental rules
randomness and consciousness
right so so this sort of potential
potential and randomness this is what's
happening in the proof of work so what
proof of work is proof of work relies
upon basically the law of random numbers
and so that's what we're we're utilizing
when you do proof of work what's
happening is that you are
you're basically let's say rolling
gigantic dice
and every single time you do this is
called a hash and what comes back is a
number
and you're fundamentally
trying to roll below a certain number
that's like astronomically hard to do
so if you tried to do this by chance i
mean
to give you an example like we're we're
talking about exa hashes that are being
done on these bitcoin networks so it's a
million million million
of these roles so that's a one with 18
zeros that you have to do every second
in order that every 10 minutes
you would come up with this number
so it's like
it's actually that it's it's your
it's less likely so there's a lower
probability of finding a bitcoin block
like on a per-hash basis than a virgin
birth would be
so it's like
they would say well a virgin birth is
like
technically possible right even like a
materialist like they'd be like okay
yeah there's some and if we had this
confluence of events and you could lay
it out that it would be like oh it's a
one in a
quintillion quadrillion
chance that it would happen right well
finding a bitcoin block is
literally
less than that
less probable than that that's why you
got to do so many roles right so you
have this entire sphere of potential
this is so it's basically
yeah so a bunch of dies being rolled and
then you have
something which recognizes the right
number let's
yes so so some set of fixed rules
so these would be like the consensus
rules but that are also related to these
mathematical truths right so they're
built on top of the one plus one equals
two right so we have these truths we
have a we have a
a box an arena whatever you want to call
it we have some framework inside every
in which everything is working and this
is the framework of nature and then you
have this very real
probability
that's going on and then you have the
interaction of logos so it's that the
logos actually is interacting with the
so the consciousness of individuals can
change some aspects of the rules
the consciousness of the individuals
is actually needed in order for somebody
to turn on their machine and actually
get it going right like it can't work by
itself right so there's so there's this
three way
so you have this reality you have the
system that's working it also has it
also needs like something to care
yes or do i need you need a you need an
agent to care about this or else like
it's not going to happen
yes exactly exactly and so this is the
very much to me
in in contemplation in prayer in in in
moving through this and again i go into
it relatively deeply in my book that
it's
this very much to me is an echo of
the
the sort of the the trifurcation if you
will of the one
god into the three persons into the the
eternal
everlasting
creator that is all everything into the
potential of the holy spirit
where it where everything is and into
the the logos of the sun into into the
care as you say into the human element
right and that it's the interaction of
all three of those that makes the system
yeah and so i'm not sure about very much
that for sure i'm not sure about the
trinitarian but what i do see for
certain is like the creation narrative
in genesis like the sure the idea of
heaven earth
and then man or you know the
the perceiver the the the agent which is
able to act as a
joining of the two together so you have
this like crazy potential that's
bubbling that's bubbling up all this
stuff
you know you have a pattern above and
then you have something in the middle
which is able to perceive that which is
valuable out of what is coming up is
able to say oh with that one that number
is the one i care about all those other
numbers they can just fall away that's
the one that matters and then that is
what kind of makes the system work let's
say
yeah i think that's i think that's very
accurate and it is also that the
the numbers themselves
i mean as you just articulated it's not
the numbers themselves that are valuable
because
getting the same number on a future
block
is not there's nothing there it doesn't
mean anything so it's not just that
you're looking for that number
right it's it's
you that you have to have a very
specific number that's tied to a very
specific history
right so and that's the that's the as
you say that's the awareness that's the
consciousness that's looking at it
and so it
when when the system is is looked at as
it is
it's very different than
and and it's very unfortunate to me
that
how it's perceived by
the public when they talk about bitcoin
and why you're absolutely right to have
suspicions about that story is that oh
this is something that i buy
and then the number goes up
and then i sell it after the number has
gone up and here i am and it's like no
it's really a lot deeper than that
there's a lot more going on and it's
brand new
all right listen we've been going for
quite a while so i think this you've
definitely brought me at least along in
understanding the manner in which it
generates value and at least you know
how we can understand it as a kind of
this cosmic pattern of
how something has meaning let's say and
so it's helpful i still need to
definitely need to think about it and
interestingly enough i guess i'm being
dragged into this right now and so i
will
i will start to to kind of experiment it
in participation with my with my son and
see you know i don't
at least for now it's not i also i don't
how can i say i'm not attached to it and
so sure like for me you know we put it
in uh put in a bit of money and we're
just kind of watching it it's like uh
it's like it's like an experiment for me
so i'm just trying to figure out what
what it is and so uh yeah so i will
continue on thanks for your
thanks for your time
and absolutely well what i would say
what i would say jonathan with that is
pull it off the exchange and put it in a
put it in a wallet and send it between
your son
send it to people
use it
right because i understand like you
you've put in the bit of money and
you're watching it go up but it's like
if you want if you do want to feel it if
you do want to explore it like you're
going to need to use it right so you're
going to see like there's ways like the
idea that you could use it it only works
if you exist within a
network of people that are
like you would i would need to be like
let's say in your network of crypto
users where we all recognize this and so
we can use it to exchange between like
amongst each other right but right now
that's i'm not i'm not in that like i
don't have a world around me where i can
say oh you know uh you know like the guy
the guy who comes and i don't know i a
guy comes from my lawn and so i like
send him some crypt i send him some
bitcoin as a as like a payment for it
let's say but that doesn't like at least
now it does at least in my world that
doesn't exist
well maybe maybe what we could do is uh
maybe for you
for your uh you know your carving class
or one of those things start accepting
cryptocurrency and if you want some help
with that yes and then you can be in the
community i will pro i will promote that
to my community and tell them go get
into jonathan's class and pay with
crypto i sell all my books for crypto i
sell my classes for uh for crypto so
it's like that will give you the
opportunity there's nothing
that allows you to feel the power more
than actually not buying it and waiting
for it to go up but to actually sell
goods and services and your labor and to
get it in exchange to use it i would
love to help you all right yes i would
love to help you do that all right i
will i will definitely keep that in mind
because i okay i think please do that i
agree with you that it's the only way
that i can really understand what it is
and so so we'll see what happens
everybody we'll sure slowly down this
path so thanks thanks for everything uh
supreme and uh and i'm for sure we'll
talk very soon thank you brother